نحييكم مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الساعه ساعه جديده ولكن التغطيه مستمره في
الواقع على قناه العربيه تغطيتنا للزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وهذه صور مباشره
خلينا نذكر باخر حصيله لاعداد الضحايا حيث
اعلن نائب الرئيس التركي ارتفاع اعداد
الضحايا في بلاده لتصل الى
1541,5
وكما ذكرنا وواحد واربعين
ونحو
اصابه مرجحا ارتفاع الحصيله اما في سوريا
فقد ارتفعت الحصيله الى 900 قتيل بحسب
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان والذي اشار
الى ان مئات المفقودين جراء الزلزال ما
زالوا تحت الانقاظ
وهذه الصور المباشره اذا يبدو بان هناك
عمليه انتشال سنتابع هذه الصور مشاهدينا
نذكر بان تركيا وسوريا دولتان تعيشان في
الواقع كارثه انسانيه على اثر هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا وهذه صور
من اضنه التركيه وعمليه انتشال هي في
الواقع عمليات الانتشار مستمره كنا تبعنا
هذه التفاصيل
ونذكر بان الاعداد اعداد الضحايا بالمئات
اعداد الجرحى بالالاف وهناك مناشدات
لمساعدات انسانيه طبعا واغاثيه فيما يخص
هذا الوضع الحرج الكارثي الذي تعيش هذه
المناطق اذا كما نتابع في هذه الصور عمليه
انتشال لجثه
مشاهدينا نذكر باننا في متابعه مستمره
لهذه الصور وفي تغطيه كذلك مستمره
للزلزال الذي ضرب شرق تركيا
او جنوب تركيا وشرق سوريا بلغت قوته 7.8
على سلم ريختر وكانت هذه الضربه في ساعات
الصباح الاولى ومن ثم كذلك كانت هناك
ضربه ثانيه او هذا ثانيه بلغت قواتها سبعه
فاصل خمسه وهذا الزلزال او هذه الهزه
الارضيه شعر بها كذلك مواطن لبنان والعراق
واليونان ودول اخرى كذلك الوضع حرج في
تركيا وسوريا ونحن نتابع هذه الصور
لعمليات الانتشار المستمره وكذلك
لصور محاوله
وجود
ربما اشخاص على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الدفاع الحاصل حيث دمر الزلزال عده مباني
في عده مدن وقرى من مدينه الدانه
تدمرت قرابه سته منازل في مدينه يعمل
الدفاع المدني الان على استخراج العراقيين
تحت الانقاذ تم عمل على اسعاف المصابين
الى المشاكل القريبه
مشاهدينا اظهر مقطع فيديو بلده عزمرين في
ريفي حلب بسوريا حيث تبدو المنازل قد سويت
بالارض وصارت حطاما بفعل الزلزال القوي
نتابع
ين
[موسيقى]
نتابع ونستطلع الاوضاع الميدانيه خاصه من
الحدود السوريه التركيه الصحفي ابراهيم
الادلبي ابراهيم اهلا بك معنا نتابع هذه
التصريحات الرسميه التي تناشد اولا
بعمليات اغاثه سريعه ونتابع حتى التزايد
في اعداد القتلى والجرحى حتى الان نتحدث
عن 900 قتيل في سوريا وما يفوق الالف
وخمسمائه قتيل في تركيا والاف الجرحى ضعنا
في الصوره ابراهيم ما الذي وردك سواء من
الجانب السوري او من الجانب التركي عما
يحدث
اهلا وسهلا بك من جديد وبجميع المشاهدين
حقيقه ما تزال فرق الدفاع المدني
والمدنيون المتطوعون والجهات المختصه
تحاول انتشار المدنيه من تحت الانقاذ في
منطقه الدانه اضافه الى كل من جنديرس التي
سوي جزء كبير منها على الارض في ريف عفرين
وايضا القرى في جبل الزاويه والقرى
المتاخمه للشريط الحدودي الشيء الذي يبعث
بالامل ان هناك العشرات من المدنيين الذين
تم انتشالهم بالساعات القليله الماضيه وتم
نقلهم الى النقاط الطبيه والمشافي من اجل
تلقي العلاج او عمليه النقص الاكسجين
وتعويضهم عما حدث
بالجران انهيار والمنازل فوق قاطنيها في
المناطق المذكوره هناك العديد من المناطق
التي تضررت في ريف حلب وريف ادلب لكن
النصيب الاكبر كما تحدثت سابقا لمدينه
لمدينه الاتاري بريف حلب ثم تليها جنديرس
ايضا بريف عفرين وسرمدا وحارم التي ايضا
تضررت بشكل كبير جدا هناك احياء في في
مدينه سرمدا سويت على الارض على راس
قاطنيها منهم من كان محظوظ تمكن من الخروج
اما البقيه ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ فمنهم من
ايضا ساهم الدفاع المدني والفرق المدنيه
هناك باخراج هؤلاء من تحت الانقاذ ومنهم
من
ابراهيم كيف تتم عمليه انتشال الجثث او
محاوله اخراج من هم على قيد الحياه خاصه
وان هذه المناطق التي تتحدث عنها طبعا
نشير الى ان ابراهيم الادلبي اصح في
الموجود من على الحدود السوريه التركيه
ولكن من الجانب السوري والقريب لهذه
المناطق وبالتالي كيف تتم العمليه خاصه
وان هذه المناطق وحلب تحديد هي منكوبه
ينقصها
كل اليات التداوي التطبيب
من قبل الزلزال حتى فكيف يتم انتشالهم هل
هناك جهود من الداخل هل هناك مساعدات ربما
اعيدوا بها
ان نتحدث دعيني اتحدث بدادا عن عمليه
الانتشار بالادوات البدائيه الدفاع المدني
والمنظمات الرئاسيه لا تملك القدره قدر
الدوله على على استخراج العالقين تحت
الانقاذ المعدات التي تملكها هي معدات
محدوده ونحن نتحدث عن منطقه جغرافيه شاسعه
وكبيره على الدفاع المدني وحتى على منظمات
العامله بشان الانساني في الداخل السوري
هناك اكثر من 4 مليون مدني منتشرين في هذه
المنطقه اتحدث عن الريف حلب وريف ادلب
هناك عدد من الناس ما يقارب المليون
والنصف يسكنون بالخيام على الحدود السوريه
التركيه هم افضل حالا للاسف اليوم
المقارنه ما بين الخيام والناس الذين
نجحوا للقيام وبين الناس الذين الان او
سقطت على روسيا منازلهم في التجمعات
السكنيه الناس الذين يقتلون بالخيام هم
افضل حالا بقليل من البقيه وفتحوا الخيام
بالنسبه العوده الى عمليه الانتشار هناك
بعض الاليات الثقيله التي يستخدمها الدفاع
المدني ولكن اذا
منطقيين اكثر في في كل مدينه في كل قريه
لا يمكن وضع هذا النوع من المعدات لان هذا
الامر غير ممكن والدفاع المدني والسلطات
الموجوده لا تملك هذه الكميه من المعدات
هناك محاوله دائما للاستجابه الطارئه
والعاجله للمعلومات والبلاغات المؤكده
التي تصل من المدنيين وشهود العيان الذين
وثقوا او شهدوا عمليه انهيار واكدوا ان
كان داخل المبنى اناس تتجه الفرق المختصه
ومعهم المدنيين المتطوعون بالادوات
البسيطه كالكريك وبعض الادوات التي كانت
تستخدم
هذه الجثث او اخراج من هو على قيد الحياه
طيب ابراهيم فيما انت تحدثنا عن الظروف من
الجانب السوري نحن نتابع صور من الجانب
التركي في دير بكر بالتحديد وهذه عمليه
انتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاذ نتحدث حتى
الان عن
قتيل ضحيه هذا الزلزال في تركيا حتى الان
وهناك من يرجح ارتفاع هذه الارقام مع
الاسف هناك الاف الجرحى كذلك نتحدث عنهم
وهذه الصور المباشره تاتينا من ديار بقره
التركيه حيث عمليه انتشال طبعا
الاجسام من صحه التعبير من تحت الانقاذ لا
نعلم ان كانوا على قيد الحياه ولكن البعض
يرجح بان هناك فيديوهات طبعا اكدت بانه
بعد ساعات هناك من انتشل على قيد الحياه
على كل سنبقى في متابعه هذه الصور من ديار
بكر يبقى الامل دائما للعائلات ولاهالي
المفقودين وهم بالالاف ابراهيم قلت بانه
تتم عمليه البحث وعمليه الانتشار بطرق
يدويه صف لنا اكثر الصوره
بطرق يدويه عبر استخدام ما يعرف بالمغراف
او الكريك الذي كان يستخدم بعمليات الحفر
سابقا او حتى عمليات الزراعه اذا اضافه
الى بعض الادوات التي ايضا كانت تمارس
بالزراعه كما يعرف بالفاس او القزمه التي
تستخدم بتكسير الحجاره ومنها ما يستخدم
كالتك لتكسير الحجاره بالبناء هذه الادوات
البدائيه يحاول اليوم المدنيون مجتمعين
بوضع يدهم بيد واحده من اجل ازاله هذه
الانقراض لانني اتحدث لا يمكن تغطيه كافه
القرى والمناطق المتضرره في شمال غرب
سوريا بالاليات الثقيله حتى ان الحكومه
المؤقته الحكومه السوريه المؤقته كانت قد
اصدرت بلاغا وتعميما منذ الصباح الباكر
بتوجيه كافه الاليات التي كانت تستخدم
بالعمليات العسكريه من اجل مساعده
العالقين تحت الانقاذ وهناك ايضا مشكله شق
الشوارع او فتح الشوارع لان المنطقه تعرضت
في صباح الامس الى عاصفه ثلجيه وتلاها
ايضا المنطق عاصفه مطريه ما زالت مستمره
على الوضع
الحال الطقس الجوي لا يساهم ابدا ولا
يساعد بعمليه الانقاذ انما يزيد ويعقد
الامور هناك كل مؤسسه او كل جهه تقوم
بالعمل بقدر المستطاع بالتخصص الذي يمكن
المساهمه به من خلال
الاكيد بانه ساعود لك بعد قليل ابراهيم
كذلك لفهم طبيعه هذه المناطق لفهم طبيعه
السكان الموجودين والصعوبات كذلك التي
تواجه هذه المناطق ساعود لك بعد قليل
ابراهيم ولكن اشير الى هذا العاجل مركز
رصد الزلازل الاوروبيه المتوسطيه يتحدث عن
وقوع اكثر من 220 او 220 هزه ارتداديه حتى
الان بعد زلزال تركيا اذا حديث عن وقوع
اكثر من 220 هزه ارتداديه حتى الان بعد
زلزال تركيا بحسب مرصد او مركزي رصد
الزلازل الاوروبي المتوسطي وكان هناك في
الواقع
عن ان
متساكنين بعض المناطق في الجانب التركي
يخشون حتى من العوده الى بيوتهم خوفا من
هذه الارتدادات ونحن بعد قليل سنفهم مدى
خطوره هذا الموضوع
متابعه هذا الموضوع ونفهم اكثر ما الذي
حدث وما الذي سيحدث في هذه الساعات
القليله القادمه مع ضيفنا من عمان الدكتور
محمود القريوتي الباحث والمختص في علم
ورصده الزلازل اهلا بك معنا دكتور محمود
دكتور محمود اسمح لي ان ابدا معك من اخر
تطورات نتحدث عن مخاوف البعض من العوده
لمنازلهم هناك البعض يتخوف من هذه
الارتدادات وكيف ستكون تداعياتها مبدئيا
المرصد نحن كنا وفينا مشاهدينا منذ قليل
بخبر مفاده بان هناك 220
حركه ارتداد ارتداديه حتى الان هل هذه
الارتدادات مستمره وممتى خطورتها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
شكرا على الاستضافه
ومساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين
نسال الله تعالى الرحمه لجميع الضحايا
والشفاء العاجل للمصابين نعم حقيقه ما حصل
اليوم فجرا هو عباره عن نشاط زلزالي كبير
ويصنف بالدرجه العاليه وهو عباره عن عاصفه
حقيقه زلزاليه بدات بزلزال قوه 7.8 تبع
هذا الزلزال الرئيسي بعد 11 دقيقه زلزال
قوي اخر بقوه 6.7 وثم توالت هذه الزلازل
تباعا واحدا تلو الاخرى وهي مستمره لغايه
الان نعم سجل ماذا تسميها زلازل وليست
ارتدادات
لانها تتبع الزلزال الرئيسي ازال رئيسي هو
الذي حدث ومن ثم تتبعها هذه الزلازل
التابعه او الارتدادات كما كما تسمى وهي
مستمر نعم نعم وهي مستمره لغايه الان
حقيقه ويتوقع ان تستمر وممكن ممكن ممكن ان
تحدث مئات هذه
الزلازل او التوابع
بقوه مختلفه طبعا هذا النشاط القوي حصل
نتيجه ولكن اسمحلي دكتور محمود لما تقول
لانها يمكن ان تستمر هذه الارتدادات
ويمكن ان تكون بقوه مختلفه ولكن
بنسب تنازليه يعني بقوه تنازليه او يمكن
ان نشهد ارتدادات قويه
كزلزال الاول والذي تبعه بعد بعض الدقائق
حقيقه هذا نوع من العواصف بدا بزلزال كبير
القوي الاولاني ومن ثم تبعه زلازل وتبدا
تقل شيئا فشيئا فما حدث وما سيحدث خلال
هذه العاصفه هي زلازل جميعها اقل من
الزلزال الرئيسي وتبدا تتناقص شيئا فشيئا
الى نهايه هذه العاصفه التي قد تستمر
حقيقه عده شهور وممكن ان تستمر الى الى
سنه لانها حقيقه نشاط زلزالي قوي ويقع على
حافه حافه صفيحتين التاني احدثت الصدع
النشيط والذي احداث هذا النشاط الزلزالي
طيب نشير الى هذا العاجل واشنطن تتحدث عن
ارسال فريق اي بحث وانقاص امريكيين
بقوه 79 فردا لكل منهما لتركيا وسوريا بعد
الزلزال
اعود لك من جديد دكتور محمود لماذا تعتبر
هذه المناطق نتحدث عن الجنوب التركي وشمال
السوري هي مناطق مهيئه لهزات ارضيه بهذه
القوه
وذلك لوجود صفيحتين
هاتان الصفيحتان تتحرك
يتحركان نسبيا هي الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه الاناضوليه
الحركه على هاتين الصفيحتين انتجى الصدع
الرئيسي في تلك المنطقه والذي يسمى بصدع
الاناضول الشرقي هذا الصدع نشيط بمعنى
نشيط انه يحصل عليه زلازل حصل عليه زلازل
سابقه ويحصل عليه زلازل حاليا فبالتالي هو
صاد نشيط ويمكن ان ان يحدث نشاطات مختلفه
وبقوى مختلفه في هذا الاطار البعض
استوقفته تغريده في الواقع لعالم وراصد
للزلازل
وتحدث منذ ثلاثه ايام عن توقعات بان يكون
هناك زلازل وحتى
الدرجه التي تحدث بها كانت قريبه جدا
للواقع هو تحدث عن سبعه فاصل وهذا ما حدث
في الواقع
كيف يفسر ذلك خاصه وانه اذا كان هذا في
اطار علمي معين فكان بالامكان مثلا
القيام ببعض الترتيبات
نعم هناك مسلمات في علم الزلازل احدى هذه
المسلمات انه لا يمكن مطلقا وبدون اي شكوك
ان اتوقع واتنبا باي نشاط زلزالي ما حدث
في مثل هذا الذي توقع هذا الشيء يعني يرجى
التاكد انه
قال هذا الشيء قبل زلزال او بعده هذا اولا
ثانيا هو قال قبل زلزال من يعني دكتور
دكتور هو قال قبل الزلزال حتى دخلت لحسابه
على تويتر ويعني مش صوره تداولها البعض لا
هناك تغريده منذ ثلاثه ايام وموجوده
نعم الان هو يعني للعاملين في هذا المجال
يمكن التوقع زلزال في هذا الحجم وهذا شيء
عادي ومقبول لدى الجمعي لدى العاملين في
هذا المجال نتوقع
زلزال في هذا القوه وفي هذه المناطق لكن
السؤال هو لا يمكن مطلقا توقع التاريخ
والوقت هنا هنا الاشكاليه توقع التاريخ
والوقت هذا لا يمكن مطلقا وهذا يعني مسلم
به في علم الزلازل طيب اود شكرك جزيل
الشكر على كل ما قدمته من معلومات
وتوضيحات الدكتور محمود
القريروتي الباحث والمختص في علم ورصد
الزلازل شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي خصوص تصريحات الرسميه وردود الفعل وجه
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بمساعده فوريه
لدعم انقره في مواجهه تداعيات الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد فجر اليوم وبحسب بيان
البيت الابيض فان اداره بايدن تعمل بشكل
وثيق مع تركيا وان المسؤولين الامريكيين
تواصلوا على الفور مع نظرائهم من الاتراك
لتنسيق اي مساعده مطلوبه
هذا وكان اوضح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
واشنطن تقيم خيارات الاستجابه الشامله
للزلازل للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا وكذا في بيان ان بلاده ستبذل كل ما
في وسعها لمساعده المتضررين خلال الفتره
المقبله مضيفا انا واشنطن على اتصال وثيق
مع انقره وشركائها في المجال الانساني
لتحديد ما تحتاجه المنطقه في الايام
القادمه بلينكن اشار الى ان جهود
الاستجابه الاوليه في تركيا جاريه بالفعل
مؤكدا ان المنظمات الانسانيه المدعومه من
واشنطن في سوريا تستجيب لي اثار الزلازل
وعلى صعيد متصل وصل وزير الدفاع التركي
خلوص يعقار الى ولايه هاتاي برفقه رئيس
هيئه الاركان يشار جولر وقائد القوات
البريه موسى اوسيفر كما بدات سبعه عشر
طائره شحن تابعه للقوات المسلحه التركيه
بتسير رحلات نجويه متواصله محمله
بالمساعدات الى ولايتي غازي عنتاب
مشاهدينا سننتقل الان لمتابعه هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي لوزراء الصحه والزراعه والدفاع في
تركيا نستمع من الاطباء والممرضات اتوا
الى هنا
ودوله وبكل مؤسساتها
تعمل
مساعده
[موسيقى]
نتجاوز هذه المحنه بالتضامن والتكافل
ودائما
الدوله ستكون الى جانب مواطنيها
ايضا
التنسيق بين الدوله وبين المؤسسات والشعب
مهم جدا في تجاوز هذه المحن
نعم
احيي جميع المواطنين سواء كانوا معنا
وسواء كانوا امام التلفزيون
بعد
قمنا بتاسيس
مركز مركز
وقمنا
العمل من اجل
سد الاحتياجات
وانقاذ المنكوبين
وقمنا
ارسال
طائره
القوات المسلحه
تمام
ايضا توظيف
المسيرات
في الحاجه وطبعا
منظمات الاغاثه
قمنا
بالجهد الكبير لايصال فرق الاغاثه من
مناطق المنكوبه ولكن فصل الشتاء والظروف
الاستثنائيه التي نمر بها
احيانا تؤخر
وصولنا الى بعض المناطق النائيه
ايضا القوات المسلحه التركيه
فرق اغاثه من القوات الخاصه
وايضا فرقه من الفرق القوات الخاصه
القبرصيه ايضا لاحق
بهذه الفرق والان تعمل من اجل مساعده
الماكوبين ونحن
عملنا
اولا
انقاذ
المنكوبين وايضا
نسعى جاهدين لتوفير
الغذاء
والاكل والطعام
المنكوبين
ايضا هناك حاجه للخيام
طبعا
الجيش التركي يعمل من اجل توفير خدمه
الخيم
للمنكوبين
المستشفى الرئيسي في المدينه لحق به ضرر
ولذلك الان نحن في صدى تاسيس مستشفى
ميداني هو متنقل
ونحاول سد هذه الفجوه وطبعا
الاشخاص الذين لم نستطيع
بمعالجتهم هنا بسبب النقص في المستشفيات
سننقلهم الى اسكندرون
ومن هناك
ستكون سفينه بانتظارهم
لتنقلهم عبر البحر الى مدينه مرسين
ايضا
في انطاكيا هناك
8900 نفر من
الجيش يقومون بمساعده الناس
نحن
نحاول جاهدين
بمساعده المنكوبين
طبعا القوات المسلحه
تعمل جاهده لاغاثه المنكوبين ومساعده
الناس
ونقوم قصاره جهدنا ونفعل ما بوسعنا
لمساعده الناس ولكن البعض ربما عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
لا يرون هذه الجهود ويواجهون الانتقادات
ومره اخرى
[موسيقى]
اترحم
الذين توفوا بفعل الزلزال واتمنى الشفاء
العاجل
للجرحى
وان شاء الله
سنفحال ما بوسعينا في هذه الفتره
لنتجاوزها
مره اخرى
اريد ان اجدد
الحاره
[موسيقى]
المجتمع التركي والشعب التركي لاول مره
اشاهد هذا
[موسيقى]
امكانيات التي تسخر من اجل تجاوز هذه
المحنه الكبيره التي لم اشاهد مثيلا لها
بحياتي
هناك طبعا
شبكات الغاز شبكات توزيع الغاز الطبيعي
والكهرباء تضررت بفعل الزلزال وبفعل قوه
هذا الزلزال او الزلازل الكثيره التي
ضربته
ضربتهما نحن في كل مره
نقوم بتعزيز
الفرق الفرق الانقاذ المحليه بفرق من
الخارج
في بعض طبعا
القطاعات
للكهرباء هي احيانا تكون
بهدف
الامن لان هناك بعض المباني المنكوبه
والتي يتم البحث عن من كوبين تحتها
وربما الكهرباء هنا تلحق ضرر بهذه العمليه
ولذلك يجب ان نتحمل بعضنا بعض الشيء هذه
الانقطاعات ستكون طبيعيه
نواجه ايضا صعوبات في الوصول الى بعض
المناطق بفعل تشقق الطرقات
[موسيقى]
طبعا بعض النقاط التي يصعب حتى على
السيارات
الكبيره المهيئه للظروف الاستثنائيه يصعب
عليها الوصول اليها لان هناك ظروف حقيقه
صعبه طرقات
منقطعه وطبعا هناك انقطاعات في الكهرباء
كما قلنا
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالمحروقات في المنطقه
نحن
ليس لدينا نقص في الكميات ولكن هناك طبعا
طلب كبير على المحروقات والبنزين
ربما ايضا هناك بعض الصعوبات في توفير
الكم المطلوب عندما يكون هناك طلب كبير
طبعا وهناك ايضا بعض الشكوى التي
وصلتنا حول موضوع
[موسيقى]
الدفع عبر كره الائتمانيه وحلينا كل هذه
المشاكل
طبعا هذا كله متعلق
الزخم والطلبه الكبير على
السلع المذكوره
مره اخرى اشكر جميع المساهمين في عمليات
الانقاذ مره اخرى ايضا ترحم
للمتوفين وايضا نطلب ابنا الله الشفاء
العاجل
للجرحى والصبر والسلوان لاسرهم
قيمه
انا ايضا
اعزائي
الصحفيين
اتمنى
الرحمه من الله سبحانه وتعالى على
ارواح المتوفين وايضا الصبر الجميل
اقاربهم
[موسيقى]
كان مركزه بازارجيك كهرباء مراكش له
التاثيرات خارج الحدود في شمال سوريا
ونحن منذ ساعات الصباحيه في افاض في
السابعه والنصف
قمنا بتسيير طائره
لم نستطيع ان نحط بمطار انطاكيا
لذلك ذهبنا الى مطارنا
وانتقلنا الى عبر البر وكان الصعوبات
حقيقه في الوصول الى هنا
ايضا
قمت بتاسيس خطه سريعه
الامر والمساعده
سياره خاصه
[موسيقى]
وزاره
الغابات والزراعه واداره المياه والري
تم نقلها الى هذه المنطقه طبعا
هذا الزلزال الذي الحق
اضرار كبيره بالعاشر محافظات طبعا
يجعلنا
للاسف نشعر
طبعا بحجمه وبقدره
بالضرر الذي الحقه بنا طبعا
ليس فقط البشر بل ايضا الحيوانات
ايضا متاثره بهذا الزلزال ونحن الان
نقوم
تاسيس خيم لتاوي الحيوانات الاليفه
الحيوانات المزارع
المنكوبين ايضا الذين ينتظرون
الاغاثه تحت الركام ونحن
نكتفي بهذا القدر كنا في متابعه هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي لمجموعه من وزراء الحكومه
التركيه
هناك تصريحات اتى عليها وزير الصحه
التركيه الذي قدم تحديثا في الواقع لاعداد
ضحايا الزلزال واشار الى ان عدد الضحايا
ارتفع الى
1651 قتيلا وبالنسبه للجرحى فانه ارتفع
الى اكثر من احد عشر الف وزير الدفاع
خلوصي اكار وزير ارتفاع التركي تحدث عن
توفير 17 طائره تابعه للقوات المسلحه
توفيرها وارسالها الى المناطق المتضرره
بالزلزال
وتقريبا كل وزراء الحكومه او على الاقل من
هم موجودون في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي اكدوا
على ان الجهود مستمره للاعانه للاغاثه
وكذلك حتى لتوفير التجهيزات
اللازمه لانتشال العالقين
وعمليات طبعا الاستشفاء والتطبيب نتابع
هذا الموضوع ولكن قبل المتابعه وقبل
استقبال الضيف
القادم من اسطنبول اسمحوا لي ان اشير كذلك
الى تحديث اخر او رده المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان كذلك تحدث عن ارتفاع حصيله قتل
الزلزال في سوريا الى 1000 وستين قتيل
ستبقى العين على هذه التطورات وهذه
الارقام مشاهدينا كارثه انسانيه بكل ما في
الكلمه من معنى وزلزال اتى على البشر
والحجر
وتداعيات هذا الزلزال ستكون طبعا
بالغه الخطوره وسنتابعها لحظه بلحظه من
اسطنبول طه اوغلو باحث في شان التركي سيد
طه اهلا بك معنا هناك
في الواقع من الجانب التركي لمحاوله على
الاقل توفير ما يجب توفيره اما فيما يخص
عمليه الانتشار او كذلك حتى عمليات توفير
التجهيزات اللازمه لاهالي الضحايا واهالي
الجرحى حدثني اولا عن الصوره من حيث انت
لان اسطنبول اليوم حتى وان لم تتضرر
ولكنها بحسب مشاهدات ليست كاسطنبول التي
نعرفها منذ فتره هناك ارتباك وهناك محاوله
لفهم ما يحدث
تحياتي لك استاذه ريمو الساده المشاهدين
اليوم بسبب الزلزال الكبير الذي دمر عدد
كبير من المدن التركيه مدينه كهرمان
هناك ملاطيا ديار بكر هناك حاله من العجز
حقيقه في يعني انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذ وخاصه
فيما يتعلق
الاحوال الجويه السيئه التي هي صادفت هذا
الزلزال هذا الزلزال كما تعلمين هو شبيه
تماما بازلزال الذي وقع في عام 99 اغسطس
كان حصيله القتلى في تلك الفتره فقط
الاربعين الف حاليا
الوسائل علامه التركيه وحتى المسؤولين قبل
قليل كما اشرت الوزير الصحه اعلن عن
ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى 1600 والجرحى الى
اكثر من 11 واعتقد الى الصباح وفي الايام
المقبله ممكن تكون هناك الحصيله مرشحه
للارتفاع حتى ان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان هو اعلن بان هناك يواجهون
العوائق الصعبه فيما يتعلق
بموضوع ان كان يعني
هناك انقطاع الكهرباء في بعض المناطق
المتضرره هناك بعض المشاكل وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالتواصل والاتصالات وهناك
فرق الانقاذ التي وصلت الى المنطقه مع
هطول الامطار والثلوج هي تعرقل وتصعب من
عمل فرق الانقاذ التي من ساعات الصباح
تقوم باعمالها دون توقف
هناك مخاوف يقول البعض خاصه في هذه
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال من العوده
لبيوتهم هل توفر اي شيء لهم على الاقل
لمحاوله مساعدتهم النفسيه قبل الجسديه
يعني هناك تركيا كما تعلمين لها تجربه في
الزلازل او صح التعبير هي وتتعايش مع
الزلازل ولكن النقطه المفاجئه والصدمه
الكبيره ان كان التركيز خلال الفتره
الاخيره الماضيه على مدينه اسطنبول كان
هناك توقعات من الخبراء الزلازل بان
اسطنبول هي تستقبل متوقعه يعني ان يقع
هناك زلزال مدمر كبير كما حصل في 99 ولكن
وقوع هذا زلزال في مدينه كهرمان مراش غازا
انتاب هو احدث حاله من الارباك لدى سلطات
التركيه التي
سارعت في الساعات الاولى بالتحرك فورا الى
المنطقه وزير الداخليه وزير الدفاع رئيس
اركان يتوجهون الى المنطقه 3000 جندي تركي
حاليا يساعدون في عمليات
انتشال يعني الجثث والبحث عن ناجين هذا
اشاره واضحه على ان المساء والكارثه
الكبيره لا تختلف كبيرا عام حصل في
السنوات او العقدين الماضيين
لما تحدثت عن تجربه تركيه في تعاملها مع
الزلازل كيف تبدو الحركه نحن تبعنا منذ
قليل مؤتمر صحفي لمجموعه من وزراء
الحكومات التركيه وزير الصحه وزير الطاقه
وزير الغابات
وزير الدفاع كذلك خلوصي اكار وتحدثوا عن
مجهود مستمر في الواقع ولكن من عندك
استاذه طه كيف هي صوره هل هناك رسائل تبث
مثلا عبر وسائل الاعلام التركيه تتحدث عن
اتخاذ اجراءات او اتخاذ الحذر من امور
معينه
وزاره الداخليه التركيه وهناك افاد وهي
اداره الكوارث هي حصرت وخاصه من هزات
ارتداديه هنا في اسطنبول وفي تركيا عاده
كلها يعني هناك زلزال تحدث هزات ارتداديه
على مدار يوم او يومين لذا هناك قلق وخوف
خاصه ان الدوله تركيا او هنا الحكومه
التركيه هي دفعت وداعت المواطنين للبقاء
في الشوارع هذه مشكله خاصه تحدثنا على ان
الهواء والجو قارص جدا هناك توفير مساكن
لهم توفير يعني خيام هناك المستشفيات غير
كافيه انصحها التعبير في هذه المناطق على
الخلافه اسطنبول مدينه كبيره
لاتاكد من هذه المعلومه الحكومه التركيه
هي التي طلبت من المتساكنين البقاء خارج
المنازل
نعم نعم هو الحكومه التركيه وزاره
الداخليه هي دعت خاصه
وتحسبا من ارتدادات اخرى حاليا يتم توفير
مساكن لهم في هذا الوقت ولكن عدد كبير
منهم يتوجهون الى المستوى الشفايات ليست
في المنطقه المتضرره ولكن في المناطق
القريبه ولكن المشكله كما اشرت لك قبل
قليل هناك الاجواء والاحوال الجويه هي
سيئه للغايه حتى تم في الساعات الاخيره
الماضيه يعني ابطال او الغاء عدد كبير من
رحلات الجويه حتى ان النائب رئيس التركي
اعلن قبل ساعات من الان هو
تعليق المدارس لمده اسبوع في عموم تركيا
بسبب الزلزال وبسبب الاحوال الجويه السيئه
الباحث في الشان التركي من اسطنبول ابقى
معنا سيد طه نتابع دائما بمحاوله فهم ما
يحدث من القاهرات الدكتور عباس شراقي
استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره دكتور
اهلا معنا دكتور ضيفي منذ قليل كان يتحدث
عن ان الدراسات التركيه في داخل التركي
كانت تتوقع توقعات كانت تشير الى زلزال
سيضرب اسطنبول ولكن هذا الزلزال ضرب
الشمال التركي ما التفسير
اواني تحياتي لحضرتك
الكريم ولكل الساده المشاهدين الحقيقه نحن
الان امام كارثه غير مسبوقه في شرق البحر
المتوسط يعني حتى لو هنقارن بزلزال 99
زلزال 99 كان شدته سبعه وسته من عشره نحن
امام زلزال شدته سبعه وثمانيه من عشره وده
تقريبا نفس قوه الزلزال في سنه 39 واللي
كان ضحاياه حوالي 33 الف قتيل في عدد سكان
تركيا اللي هو يعتبر يمكن ربع السكان
الحالي
وبالتالي هذه الكارثه نحن الان ليس امام
زلزال نحن امام سلسله من الزلازل اللي وصل
عادتها اكتر من 220 زلزال منهم اربع زلازل
كبرى اللي من 7.8 الى 6.2 وكان يكفي زلزال
واحد فقط لكي يسبب ضمار في تركيا او في
سوريا فما بالنا باربع زلازل كبرى الفرق
بينهم اما ساعه او ساعتين وما زالت هذه
الزلازل مستمره حتى الان والزلازل وبعدين
هذه الزلازل ليست
توابع لمكان واحد ال 220 زلزال دول في
حوالي خمسين مكان مختلفين عن بعض يمكن
المكان الاكبر اللي هو المنطقه الحدوديه
ما بين تركيا وسوريا هي اللي فيها الزلازل
الكبرى خاصه الزلزال الاول لكن احنا امام
اكثر من خمسين مكان فيهم زلازل حتى غرب
اقصى غرب تركيا على السواحل البحر المتوسط
موجود فيها جنازه بل وصلت الزلازل الى
جزيره صقليه ما التفسير يعني حضرتك تتحدث
عن اربع زلازل كبرى واكثر من 150 هناك
يعني
حديث عن 2002 120 ارتداد او زلزال ولكن
الاربع زلازل الكبرى نادرا ما تحدث بان
تكون هناك
متتاليه بنفس درجه القوه تقريبا ما تفسير
ذلك
هو الحياه يعني ما حدث الزلزال الاول كان
قويا للغايه يعني سبعه وثمانيه من عشره ده
اكبر شده زلزاليه في هذه المنطقه لم نسجل
حتى سنه 39 كان نفس الشده وبالتالي ما
كانش فيه يعني اكبر من كده على مدار
التاريخ فاذا احنا امام زلزال قوي للغايه
المنطقه التركيه هي منطقه منطقه تصدعات
كبيره والتقاء شرائح ارضيه للقاره
الافريقيه مع القاره الاوروبيه والاسيويه
وفي الشريحه العربيه وفي شريحه خاصه
لتركيا في منطقه الاناضول في منطقه تركيا
محصوره ما بين فالقين كبيرين فالق شمالي
وفالك اخر بنسميه شرق الاناضول اللي حصل
فيه الزلازل الكبرى لما بيحصل زلزال قوي
بيحفز ويشجع الفوالق الاخرى اللي في
الاماكن المجاوره وبالتالي نحن لا نشهد
نشاط زلزال في المنطقه التركيه وفي شرق
البحر المتوسط ليس فقط في جنوب تركيا ولكن
في كل المنطقه نحن نشهد الزلازل في كل
مكان الان ولذلك يعني المواطنين في تركيا
مع سوريين ان هم يخشوا ان هم يدخلوا
منازلهم حتى لو كانوا في اسطنبول او اي
مدينه تركيه لان الزلزال ليس بعيدا عنهم
ممكن يحصل في اي مكان وبالتالي هم لهم
الحق بالفعل انهم يخشوا من التوابع او او
من زلازل اخرى بتنشط في خلال الساعات وبل
الايام القادمه فاحنا امام احنا الانسان
دلوقتي لازم يعرف حجمه ان احنا عاجزين عن
ان احنا نمنع هذه الزلازل او حتى نتنبا
بها وبالتالي كل دعائنا ان يلطف ربنا
بهؤلاء
السكان في تركيا وفي سوريا وخاصه في سوريا
عندنا ضعف الامكانيات وصعوبه الجو
المباني القديمه المتهلكه
فاضحايا كثيرين ولذلك هناك نداء الان لكل
الدول بمساعده اخواننا في سوريا وتركيا
لانتشال يعني اولا الضحايا اللي موجودين
تحت الانقاض لهم الاولويه الان لان
الدقيقه الواحده تفرق مع تخيلوا ان يكون
في شخص تحت الانقاد وعليه خرسانه واحنا
دلوقتي بقى لنا 16 ساعه وطبعا كل ساعه تمر
يعني الدقيقه تفرق لانقاص حياه مواطن
فاحنا ما ننتظرش للصباح على كل الدول ترسل
احنا عايزين للمبنى الواحد مجموعات فرق
انقاذ وليس مجموعه واحده وبكل المعدات وفي
دول اجهزه صحيح هذه ماساه هذه كارثه
انسانيه ضربت هذه المناطق تحدثت عن الحاله
الخاصه السوريه وربما نتحدث عن هذا
الموضوع باسهاب ولكن في حلقات اخرى ساكتفي
معك بهذا القدر دكتور عباس شراقيت شكرك
جزيلا الشكر استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه
القاهره شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور اعود من جديد
الى اسطنبول او الى اسطنبول استاذ طه
الوضع صعب
هناك كارثه حلت بهذه المناطق نتحدث عن
تركيا نتحدث عن جهود نتحدث عن مجموعات
اغاثه او على الاقل فرق اغاثه ولكن نتحدث
كذلك عن ساعات قادمه لا نعلم ما الذي يمكن
ان يحدث فيها وبالتالي كيف هي او كيف هو
الوضع للتحذير مما يمكن ان يحدث حدثني عن
المستشفيات حدثتني عن محاوله توجه البعض
اماكن ولكن هل هذه الاماكن امنه وكيف يتم
الذهاب لها
يعني كما تفضل ضيفك قبل قليل بان حاليا كل
تركيا هي مهدده للزلزال وخاصه ان هناك
حاله من القلق في بعض المناطق التي لم
تشهد نتحدث عن هناك يعني سوء الاحوال
الجويه وحتى التنقل بين المدن وبين
المناطق اتحدث لك عن اسطنبول هنا يعني
تقريبا من منطقه الى منطقه اصبحت الحياه
نوعا ما مشتوله بسبب تساقط الثلوج يعني
صعوبه يعني التنقل وايضا ليس فقط
بالسيارات ولكن حتى في التنقل عبر
الطائرات يعني اسطنبول الغت بالامس 171
رحله جويه من والى اسطنبول اعتقد هذه هي
محنه وكارثه كبيره وهي اختبار بالنسبه
للحزب الحاكم الرئيس اردوغان الحكومه
التركيه خاصه هي كما اشارت لك عود واكرر
هي شبيهه بالكارثه التي وقعت في تركيا في
تسعه وتسعين ولكن هناك نلاحظ ان هناك
تكاتف من الشعب التركي بكافه يعني توجهاته
بكافه اطرافه وشرائحه من اجل يعني التضميد
هذه الجراح وخاصه ان يعني اذا تابعتي
الزلازل التي وقعت في تركيا في السنوات
الماضيه وحتى في عام 2020 كان هناك زلزال
قال ولكن كانت تحدث في فصل الصيف في فصل
الصيف على الاقل الخروج الناس في الشوارع
من الممكن يعني البقاء قلق وخوف ولكن نحن
نتحدث عن هناك كارثه اخرى وهي كارثه
الثلوج والاحوال الجويه السيئه هي تضاف
الى هذه الماسه وتصاحب وتعرقل من يعني
الخطه التي تقوم بها الحكومه
الوقت خاصه ولهذا السبب سالته كانت
الحكومه التركيه وفرت
اماكن لاقامه هؤلاء الاهالي
العائلات التي يمكن حتى لم تتضرر ولكن من
من مخاوفها هي خرجت من هذه بنايات واختارت
ان تتوجه لاماكن اكثر امنا هل وفرت
الحكومه ذلك
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه وحسب المعلومات نعم
هو تم توفير وليس بالعدد الكافي لنتحدث
كما اشرت لك قبل قليل بانه كان الحدث
مفاجئ جدا للجانب التركي ولا حتى الاتراك
بهذا الحجم وهذا القدر وهذه القوه حصول
هذا الزلزال في هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر
غير جاهزه كما اشرت لك لاستقبال زلازل
بهذه القوه لذا الحكومه التركيه ودفعت
كافه وزرائها وحتى رئيس الاركان ووزير
الدفاع الى المنطقه لتدارك الامور
والانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه خاصه ان هناك
يعني خوف ان تستمر عمليات الانقاذ لا اقول
يوم يومين اسبوع او اكثر خاصه يعني هناك
صعوبه في يعني البحث عن ناجين على الرغم
من ان سمعنا وهناك بعض الاخبار ان عدد
كبير من دول عربيه بادرت وتواصلت مع
الجانب التركي عدد كبير من الدول
الاوروبيه ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي والناتو
هي تواصلت مع تركي عند الدبلوماسيه
الزلزال صحه التعبير تسميتها هي متواصله
وخاصه في هذا الحدث الانساني والصرف
الصعبه التي تمر به تركيا نعم ونحن نبقى
في متابعه دائما ابقى معنا استاذ طه نحن
نبقى في متابعه هذه الصور مشاهدينا
نذكر بما اتينا عليه من اخبار حتى الان
نتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى
1610 بحسب وزير الصحه التركيه نتحدث عن
1651 عن ارتفاع عدد الجرحى الى اكثر من
احد عشر الف نتحدث عن تحركات تركيه
لمحاوله توفير كل ما يلزم اما الانتشار
العالقين او كذلك لعمليه الاحاطه بالاهالي
والمتسكنين
والموجودين في المناطق المتضرره من هذا
الزلزال على الجانب السوري كذلك كنا نتحدث
مع ضيفنا في بدايه هذه الساعه من التغطيه
حدثنا عن حال خارج للغايه عن كارثه
انسانيه يعيشها الشمال السوري الذي طبعا
هناك مناطق منكوبه في لانها تفتقد لاليات
التطبيب والمشافي وليس هناك شيء متوفر
لمحاوله على الاقل انتشال العالقين يقول
بانه عمليات الانشاء الانتشار تحصل بطريقه
بدائيه والمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان تحدث
عن ارتفاع حصيله قتل الزلزال في سوريا الى
1600 وهذه صور مشاهدينا نتابعها الان
مباشره نستكون من بعضها هذه التغطيه
[تصفيق]
يا لطيف
هذا مشاهدينا وكانت اعلانات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن انشائي مشفى ميداني في قاعده
احميم في سوريا لتقديم المساعده لضحايا
الزلزال وجاء في بيان الوزاره بانه تم
انشاء مجموعه متنقله من المسعفين
العسكريين الروس في قاعده تحميمهم الجويه
وهي في حاله تاهب دائم لتقديم المساعده
باكثر من 300 عسكري و60 وحده من المعدات
العسكريه تشارك في اعمال المساعده اضافه
الى ان القوات الروسيه تنشئ او انشات ست
مراكز لتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه في
المدن السوريه
نذهب الى الجانب السوري من دمشق معنى
الكاتب الصحفي عبد الحميد توفيق استاذ عبد
الحميد اهلا بك
البعض يقول بانه في هذه الظروف
تتلاشى كل الحسابات السياسيه
فكيف يمكن مساعده هذه المناطق في الشمال
السوري
مساء الخير لك اهلا بك الكريم والساده
المشاهدين اعتقد بان هذا الكلام دقيق وهذا
الكلام يصلح الان ولا يصلح في اماكن اخرى
اليوم الحاله الانسانيه يجب ان تتقدم على
كل الحسابات والمشاريع السياسيه وعلى كل
المشاريع التي يمكن ان توظف هكذا حاله
انسانيه الى باهداف سياسيه او لغايه
سياسيه الواقع بان الكارثه التي حلت وهي
كارثه طبيعيه حلت بسوريا وبتركيا على
وضحاياها من الجانبين الشعب السوري والشعب
التركي كانت قاسيه كانت مدهشه كانت مفاجئه
بالنسبه للجانب السوري على الاقل وكذلك
بالنسبه للجانب التركي علما بان تركيا
موجوده على خط الزلازل كما تؤكد يؤكد كل
علماء الجيولوجيا وكانت دائما حين تحدث
هزات زلزاليه فيها تتاثر بعض المناطق ولكن
ليس بهذا الحجم في زلزال تسعه وتسعين وكان
وت
الطبيه ليست كما يجب كما كانت عليه قبل
الاحداث عشر سنوات وكذلك الحال وربما اكثر
صعوبه وتعقيدا الامر بالنسبه للمناطق التي
لا تخضع لي سيطره الدوله السوريه في ريف
ادلب وبعض المناطق الاخرى في ايضا باتجاه
شمالي حلب باتجاه الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا
وبالتالي اعتقد بان الامتحان الرئيسي
اليوم هو
للضمير الانساني الدولي ضمير المجتمع
الانساني الدولي سمعنا كثيرا حتى الجانب
التركي والجانب السوري اليوم ايضا ناشد
الامم المتحده ومنظماتها بان تكون ان
تتحمل جزءا من المسؤوليه الانسانيه في هذا
الامر وتقدم الدعم لسوريه ومن اجل تسريع
عمليه
انتشال الضحايا وتسريع عمليه رفع الانقاظ
عسى خاصه استاذ عبد الحميد خاصه وكما تعلم
حضرتك نحن نقشنا في حلقات او نشرات سابقه
ناقشنا الوضع الصعب في هذه المناطق
بالتحديد في الشمال السوري تعلم حضرتك بان
هذه المناطق هي لا تتوفر فيها ادنى سبل
العيش هناك مخيمات وهناك منازل متهالكه
فالوضع سيكون اصعب عليهم في الساعات
القادمه خاصه مع سوء الاحوال الجويه
صحيح هذا الكلام دقيق وكذلك ساهم المناخ
بالمصادفه ان يكون كذلك وهناك عامل اخر في
تلك المناطق التي نكبت ايضا في الشمال
السوري لا تخضع لي الدوله السوريه لا توجد
مؤسسات حقيقيه طبيه
اقتصاديه صحيه لوجستيه تكون قادره على
تنظيم العمل وبالتالي لا توجد ادوات عمل
ربما تكون كافيه لهذا الامر ولذلك اعود
واقول بان اليوم الجانب الانساني يجب ان
يتخطى كل الحسابات السياسيه حتى على
الجانبين اليوم سوريا وتركيا الشعب السوري
والشعب التركي يشتركان في محنه
عبد الحميد هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن التغطيه
مستمره على قناه العربيه عبد الحميد توفيق
الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا من دمشق وتعزيز
لكل
مشاهدينا ومتابعينا في سوريا وفي تركيا
وكل الشعب التركي والسوري